what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so really for the last few months
or so we've been kind of goofing off
when it came to DC rebirth and a lot of
us because of the fact that we've been
doing like Dark Knight's metal and we've
been doing like Watchmen different
things like that but we are behind like
we are so behind on DC rebirth it is
pitiful so over the course of the next
few weeks or so we're gonna play
catch-up
like we're we're doing a huge DC rebirth
dump and we're starting this all off
with Red Hood and The Outlaws now to get
us caught up here for those of you guys
who were you know who's who saw the
first Red Hood in the outlaws video and
haven't really read it since Red Hood in
the outlaws in DC rebirth it's like this
natural progression of Jason Todd's
character even taking out of the
equation things like reboot so it's like
you know pretend new 52 never happened
you know Jason Todd was a pre-crisis
character he showed up before crisis on
Infinite Earths his origin story was
just like Dick Grayson fans hated it DC
tried to give him a new origin fans
still didn't like it there so at the
request of the fan base DC killed him
off they replaced him with Tim Drake you
know several years later Jason Todd came
back after the events of Infinite Crisis
he became the Red Hood and fans loved it
because it gave him direction he was
kind of this outlier character who was
just sort of out there you know he was
part of the bad family but at the same
time he wasn't part of the bat family he
was willing to be a lot more brutal than
Batman was this ran all the way up into
the new 52 DC paired him up with Arsenal
and it was interesting for a while but
people were wanting more of like the
dark and brooding Jason Todd they
weren't really shooting for like the
buddy cop story and it was interesting
you know for the time that we had it but
DC rebirth sets Jason Todd backs her
back to rights that was the whole basis
of Red Hood in the outlaws it was let's
set Jason Todd back to the kind of
character that fans are most familiar
with and then let's keep him there for a
little while and so with Scott lo Dell
riding the story the nature of Jason
Todd and DC rebirth really fit in nicely
with the whole red cut Red Hood concept
in the sense that he was basically
tasked by Batman with finding some
connection between some criminal element
and like you know a mayor and then
ultimately it turned out the Mayor was
infected with a virus and the Jason Todd
pretended to assassinate the mayor in
order to cure him and then basically
look like the mayor was dead and then
give himself away into the criminal
underworld it was one of these things
where Jason Todd was willing to do some
pretty seedy things or at least what
looked to be some pretty seedy things in
order to achieve his goal he was starkly
different from Bruce Wayne now the
introduction of other characters like
Artemus like bizarro those were really
just kind of like happenstance
right it's just one of those things
where their past just kind of crossed
you know Artemis was on the hunt for the
of raw which we'll explain in this video
bizarro had been created by Lex Luthor
back when he was still a bad guy in
order to find a way to defeat Superman I
mean these characters have just kind of
been thrown out there and by virtue of
just great riding they crossed over into
the path of Jason Todd and they formed
the Dark Trinity Red Hood Artemis and
bizarro and they've basically been a
team ever since and the storytelling and
this is fantastic in that the way this
kicks off is it really focuses on the
state of Corrick now this brings into
sharp relief the idea of Artemis in
terms of who she is and what she's about
because what this does is basically it
seems kind of the return of a woman by
the name of a killer
now this begins to do things like bring
in some history of the the nature of DC
Reapers so as we know and as we've
talked about before
do you see rebirth is designed to grab
themes that existed before DC rebooted
with the new 52 and roll them into you
know DC at the moment and when it came
to the character of Artemis she's not
new in fact she's been around since
Wonder Woman number 90 in 1994 and the
whole idea behind this was to begin
introducing themes that could bolster
Wonder Woman's popularity remember
George Perez's creation of bond amygdala
I think is how you pronounce it back in
1990 89 1990 something like that it was
designed for the purpose of basically
saying there's more Amazons out there
than what you see in thermosphere
there's more than just Wonder Woman it's
like when geoff johns grabbed the Green
Lantern so there's actually more green
more Lantern cores than just the Green
Lantern's and the yellow lanterns
there's a lot going on out there and the
whole basis behind this was to again
bolster the Wonder Woman landscape
bolster those stories you know Bonham
McDowell is basically this land of
Amazon's that basically broke off from
the mascara thousands of years
beforehand and took up residence in
Egypt now the cool thing about this is
that it also saw crossovers I saw you
know it really kind of establishes
animosity between these two tribes the
fact they didn't really see eye to eye
you had the bottom ik doll Amazon's and
then you had the thermosphere and
Amazon's and that was really about it I
mean that was you know you didn't have a
whole lot going on there and so DC
gravity those concepts and rolling them
in seeing the return of Aquila and the
return of the concept of the of the shim
tar I think is how you pronounce it it's
sort of this return to familiarity for a
lot of people who have been reading
Wonder Woman comics for years now again
the free scimitar shim tar however you
wanna pronounce it is really designed
this kind of be the champion of the
people it's kind of like the the bottom
McDonnell version of Wonder Woman which
is the sake where Wonder Woman was
really more of a exploratory character
being that you know Diana just kind of
left the mascara went on went into her
own thing for Artemis it's really more
of a tangible thing in the sense that
it's not an idealistic superhero it's
the actual champion of their people now
at the outset what this does is it grabs
this idea that there's something called
the bow of raw and the bow of raw is
really like the most powerful weapon
that the bottom ik doll have at their
disposal and the idea was that only a
select person can use it basically the
shim tar of the of the bottom ik dog
initially Artemis thought it was hurt
and that was an on writing theme back in
the older days of Wonder Woman vacuum
the Jorge Perez stories of different
things like that it was the idea that
Artemis was the shim tar she was the
protector of the bottom ik doll people
with regards to DC rebirth it sort of
modified that a little bit and it simply
says that a Killough was the shim tar
and a killer was the only person who
could really wield the bow of raw the
problem with this was that because she
wasn't really ready for it ultimately
the bow got the better of her and so
because of the fact that the bottom
MacDonald took up residence in karach
and they were constantly trying to be
pushed out by you know whatever dictator
was running the show at the time
ultimately a killer was corrupted by the
bow and she started using the bow to
basically wipe out her own kingdom as
well as trying to take out those
Karachi's and the result was that Wonder
Woman showed up eventually talked to
Artemis into and you know an ally of
sorts and then ultimately they took out
a killer or at least it was believed
that she was basically dead and so this
is the whole basis behind it because
during that conflict the bow of raw had
vanished and that's what set Artemis on
this trail resulting in her meeting up
with Red Hood and then basically
becoming part of the Dark Trinity and so
of course you know the fact that they're
being brought to karach the fact that
you know we basically have you know Red
Hood and Artemis and bizarro looking for
them over on order to assist Artemis and
her mission this of course brings
bizarro and who basically lays waste to
everybody now again the funny thing
about this is that because of the fact
that bazaar was designed to kind of be
this clone of Superman albeit with
broken English it works it works pretty
well because we look at his character
and the idea is that he's doing what he
thinks is right he's doing what he
believes to be the right thing the issue
with this is that somebody fires the bow
of raw or at least that you know some
kind of an explosion goes off and
everybody's just kind of separated and
split off into different locations now
again that's the nature of this whole
idea of Red Hood in The Outlaws because
of the fact that this story took place
by like the ninth the eighth or ninth
issue in the run what it basically men
is that it was the goal of Scott l'hotel
to build the characters individually as
well as focus on them as
and that's just kind of a hallmark to
all the years that Scott Lowe Dells been
writing comics he's one aware on how to
build characters and that's the nature
of it is to build up the individuals to
give you a reason to care about them so
that when you have a team book that
comes together you're vested in each of
the individual characters and you're
essentially rooting for the team to
succeed and so of course with bizarro
basically crash landing and karach
proper which is to say surrounded by all
these different citizenry they think
he's Superman as of course in their mind
it is well Superman's the protector of
the people not just you know the
metropolis but the world and so he can
help us out of this he can get rid of
this dictator force or something along
those lines now because of the fact that
bizarro is trying to be a good guy his
responses I'll protect you as best I can
and I'll make sure that you guys are
safe from me from the generals forces
now from here switches over to Jason
Todd and this is one of the most
important aspects of his writing because
he's taken prisoner near the exact same
building he was killed in and that's why
this is so cool is because this sort of
breezed back to those individuals who
basically picked up Red Hood and The
Outlaws with DC Reaper and they never
read anything about Jason Todd before
this covers all that it talks about how
DC wanted to get rid of Jason Todd
because fans didn't like him they
basically told a story where Jason
believes he tracked down his birth
mother has eventually led to karak the
Joker showed up ambushed him beat him
with a crowbar and then blew him and his
mom up and then Jason Todd was dead
these are the things that basically feed
into this whole concept but with regard
to Jason Todd himself it's him kind of
facing his own past and that's the
importance of it is because it's one of
those things he didn't necessarily deal
with to a degree he did but only insofar
as the writing allowed it when he
originally came back building an
animosity between Red Hood and Batman
was limited to why didn't you avenge my
death
after the Joker killed me and that was
really about it this kind of deep
character exploration didn't really
happen not only that picking back up
with Artemis we end up finding out that
a killer is still alive and so again
maybe maybe it's a key I'm not a hundred
percent sure how you would pronounce
that but the fact remains here that it
is interesting to me because this goes
into the nature of Artemis you know with
Artemis as a character sitting down
basically having been someone who had to
kill her own sister because remember
despite the fact that the bottom
McDonnell Amazon's do not hail from
famous Kira they're still extremely
tight-knit there are sisters we have to
protect them in all cost they're still
very very close to each other not only
that where Artemis and akia at least a
kill as far as I recall in the pre 232
landscape back there in the 90s where
they were extremely close friends Scott
Lowe dealt he's as the idea
they were actually romantically involved
you know these Mullins is this kind of a
scenario when Jason Todd sits inside of
his own mind switching back to his
character and he's reliving and watching
his own death at the hands of the Joker
this you know younger version of himself
you know is basically saying help me you
got to save me and Jason Todd responses
there's no way to save you because I
already died this already happened this
happened years ago and this is all just
playing out in my mind now of course he
does end up taking out the Joker and he
does end up you know essentially killing
him and saving young Jason Todd but this
is his own minds way of dealing with his
own history and conquering his own fears
and that's the important thing about
this because of the fact that Joker had
killed Jason Todd during the death in
the family storyline the whole idea was
that it was always a part of his
character and it was something he never
fully dealt with this is coming in and
being written by Scott Liddell is
basically saying we're finally putting
this to bed and that's what Scott
Liddell is doing he's basically saying
there's more to Jason Todd than the fact
that he was killed by the Joker and
brought back using a Lazarus Pit so
let's explore what that is let's find
out what that is and let's just see
where that road takes us this ultimately
leads to essentially aquila bring him
back this whole story in in and
basically saying look when you and
Wonder Woman fought me and you guys were
forced to kill me ultimately I was
basically brought back by the general
the general took those the BOA raw or at
least bought it off of black mask
ultimately the general brought me back
because of the fact the general couldn't
wield it he wasn't able to use it and so
his idea was to basically clone me so to
speak bring me back and then turned me
into his own weapon now the cool thing
about this is that the way this plays
out is just kind of one of those things
where it's like I mean you know we never
really knew what road this would take us
in and I was never really sure what
would happen but what I do know is that
our people are back we want you back
here Artemis and that's a very important
thing for her character because she's
basically been on this journey and is
actually left bottom ik dog and gone on
this whole quest to find the the bow of
rock the idea is that she's grown beyond
the bounds of the home she came from and
so because of that she's almost torn at
or loyalty to Red Hood and to bizarro or
as she also has this drive to return
back to the life that she had before
well there's no more tracking down bad
guys living your life in a simple way in
some hidden Egyptian town it really kind
of tugs on the heartstrings of what it
means to be a sentient being now of
course this leads directly into the
whole idea of Red Hood originally
escaping his captives you know being
confronted by the general taking other
generals forces and of course putting a
gun of the general himself but the
question is what's going on and where is
the bow of raw
general's responses I had it but I don't
have it anymore because it was stolen
from me and that's what we ended up
finding out that akela still has the bow
of Rod not only that she's still
corrupted by the power she possesses so
it's really really cool because it
basically builds on this idea that there
is no going back there's no way to
return to the life that you came from
Red Hood showing up alongside the
general you end up having Aquila and the
various forces alongside Artemis who
essentially show up and they're like we
have to take these guys out these guys
are constantly trying to tear down the
society we live in
they're constantly trying to push us out
they're trying to steal our home it is
really intriguing because the initial
response of Red Hood is yeah but akela
is the one that has the bow rock and
she's the one who's still corrupted now
Artemis desire to return home to a life
of simplicity almost trumps the idea of
Red Hood and that's the nature of these
relationships that's why it's so cool is
because if this were just a general
superhero story let's say for example
this story was written in the 1950s one
it wouldn't be anywhere near that dark
and - Artemis would have been like Oh
akela has the has the Balrog with a
let's get her instead instead you know
what the way comics have progressed over
the decades the whole idea behind this
as characters become more tangible and
they become more grounded and so Artemis
response is exactly the way ours would
be well it's not true no way she has
that bow because if she has the bow it
means she's still corrupted which means
that even if she came back it's a core
part of her character now meaning that
my friend and presumably former lover
kid never returned to a state of
normalcy
she can never go back to being a good
guy again and if she can never go back I
can never go back which means I'm stuck
in this life now it hits in the nature
of people and so effectively the life of
Artemis to a degree is brought full
circle it's brought right back around
again because it's this idea that now
Artemis has to be the one to take out
her friend and so of course this leads
directly into you know of course bizarro
showing up along side all these other
guys you know and of course our killer
tries to take down bizarro as best she
can ultimately it's not the best
decision one could make she's able to
pull it off to a degree but her massive
use of this weapon really impacts
bizarro because it almost seems like it
kills him now of course this leads
directly into like Red Hood and these
guys you know Artemis so on and so forth
then being able to take out a kill and
just by virtue of the fact that Artemis
takes the bow of wrong and what this
does is it establishes her as being the
shim tar and this simply means that she
is supposed to be that person that she
is destined to be the protector of her
people
it's basically continuing to kind of
build these themes and the future of
where the story main
and what may end up happening the
problem with all this is that by virtue
of you know bizarro being hit by this
bowl of rock the masses surge of energy
it effectively seems like it's going to
kill his character now this allows us to
cover a little bit of the history when
it comes to the character of his arm and
he is really interesting and maybe we
could get away with doing like a
character explanation video on him but
he's been around since the Superboy
number 68 in 1958 and he was created by
Otto bender I think it was and again
that was all really back in the day when
you basically had you know Mort
Weisinger running the show and he was
like something new every six months
don't care what it is it needs to be
Superman related it needs to be a
version of Superman or something called
super and it has to be introduced every
six months so the cool thing about
bizarro is that over the years from the
time he was first introduced all the way
up to the modern day he's always been
depicted as just kind of a dumbed down
version of Superman now a lot of things
have been expanding you've had bizarro
world you've even had bizarro Batman
you've had all these things that have
gone on with his character as time has
progressed but the kind of development
that you're seeing with him now is
actually new for the most part focusing
on this idea the bizarro was a version
of Superman created by Lex Luthor to
destroy Superman
you know the idea the bizarro is kind of
being reworked and revamped this kind of
rewriting this going on here it's
actually pretty significant and it's
pretty huge I mean there have been
writers who have touched on things like
this but not quite like this that's what
makes this so intriguing is because
Artemis in Red Hood genuinely care about
bizarro for these guys they're cast offs
in a lot of ways that's why bizarro fits
in so well these characters are in a lot
of ways cast doubts and so with bizarro
just kind of being this twisted clone of
Superman these three have effectively
formed a family for themselves they're
building that relationship they're
building that friendship and they're
kind of at a point where they don't want
to lose these other guys so because of
this bizarro systematically being shut
down coincides with the return of
solomon grundy now solomon grundy is an
interesting talking point when it comes
to DC Comics a lot of people will say
The Incredible Hulk is a copy of solomon
grundy solomon grundy did appear before
the Incredible Hulk but it wasn't until
the Incredible Hulk appeared that
solomon grundy was revamped into his
current form Hulk was so popular that DC
kind of took that concept and rolled it
into solomon grundy it is kind of
interesting with that but for the most
part run Hood and Artemis stand no
chance against solomon grundy
you're talking about a guy who one is
effectively immortal and two even
Superman will struggle with and so is
one of these things worse like okay look
they can do the best they can't but at
this point they're a stopgap measure and
they're a very short stopgap measure
biggest solomon grundy would waste these
guys in almost no time at all now with
bizarro s-- you know suffering from
cellular degeneration he kind of ignores
that flies into the scene incapacitate
him and call it a day basically you know
since solomon grundy out set him on his
way beat him unconscious and leave him
there but the problem with this is that
as he's been doing this he's been
exerting all this energy and effectively
is quote-unquote dying now it's one of
the saddest moments in the world because
he tells Red Hood he was like keep an
eye on pop up it's the funniest thing
it's like it's funny and it's sad it is
and it's adorable it's very childlike in
terms of how this works is one of the
reasons why I dig this so much but
ultimately the quote-unquote death of
bizarro is really you know kind of
halted he receives this kind of stay of
execution at the hands of Lex Luthor I
remember because of the fact that the
early days of the new 52 saw Lex Luthor
basically being a bad guy trying to find
ways to take out Superman and then
creating bizarro for that purpose with
the event of forever evil basically
seeing the crime syndicate the evil
version of the Justice League invading
the main DC Universe due to the fact
that anti-monitor was wiping out their
reality allow my way out reality's left
and right this for selects Luthor to
make his own Justice League team in
order to save the world and because of
the fact that he had become a hero it
changed his character
it was DC basically saying so what if
Lex Luthor became a good guy and then
stayed a good guy and that's why you're
seeing Lex Luthor the way you are right
now in DC rebirth but because of the
fact that he's the one that created
bizarro he's the best person suited to
fix bizarro and that's exactly how this
plays out you end up having Artemis and
Red Hood recollect on their experiences
with bizarro you know Jason Todd playing
video games with him you know I have no
idea what video game they would play
together but it looks fun it's almost
like one of these movie montage scenes
when you know where a person looks back
on all the greatest moments of their
lives with a friend they're about to
lose but because of the fact that
bizarro is designed to be this sort of
opposite of Superman the question of Lex
Luthor is if green kryptonite in the
veins of Superman would kill him what
will it do to you now this kind of
stretches the bits of credulity and it's
really kind of Scott low down saying hey
guys just go with it just don't question
it too much just sort of run with it and
let's just see what happens
and so we're a green kryptonite would
normally kill Superman and Lex Luthor
says well you're the opposite of
Superman so if green kryptonite would
kill Superman
then it'll heal you let's inject it
let's just see what happens and
ultimately is interesting because Lex
Luthor comes back out after this
quote-unquote
surgical work Red Hood and Artemis go in
not only is bizarro healed bizarro is
now a genius he's exactly what it seems
like he was meant to be super smart
higher-level reasoning is it's crazy
he's he's the opposite of bizarro now
but he's not Superman so what does that
make him I have no idea I have no idea
what the answer to that question is but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain to make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob Court if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]